ici dans cette pièce on est dans le labo
du blob on étudie le comportement d'un
organisme qui n'est pas un animal qui
n'est pas un végétal et qui n'est pas
une plante c'est un organisme un peu
unique malgré qu'il soit composé d'une
seule cellule et donc il n'a pas de
système nerveux il est tout à fait
capable de résoudre des problèmes que
l'on peut juger complexes je prépare une
expérience avec des ponts pour du coup
une expérience de prise de décision je
vais mettre un blog au milieu et ensuite
on va avoir de quel côté ils dirige ici
on a notre expérience vieillissement on
aimerait bien savoir son secret
d'immortalité le vlog il peut faire
plein de choses qu'on comprend pas
toujours ces résultats ils remettent en
question la notion d'intelligence je
suis Audrey dussutour je suis directrice
de recherche au CNRS et je suis
spécialiste du blob ce bureau c'est un
peu la caverne d'Alibaba on a
#lobe là on a une classe qui a fait des
petits origamis un par un et ici on a un
blob
tricoté par une grand-mère le blob est
rentré dans la culture pop je crois
donc là c'est des expériences où on
démontre que le blob est capable
d'apprendre quand le blob rencontre un
répulsif pour la première fois il a
énormément de difficultés à se déplacer
sur le pont mais si on demande au blob
de faire ça plusieurs fois ce qu'on va
voir au bout d'un certain temps c'est
que le blob arrive à se déplacer très
rapidement sur le pont même si c'est le
même pont et là où le blob ne s'arrête
pas là bien sûr c'est que comme il peut
fusionner avec ses congénères il peut
transmettre cet apprentissage à un blog
complètement naïf s'il fusionne avec lui
assez résultat ils remettent en question
bien sûr la notion d'intelligence mais
aussi la notion d'apprentissage puisque
quand on voit la définition d'un
apprentissage on s'appuie souvent sur le
système nerveux le blob il nous démontre
que finalement n'a pas besoin de système
nerveux pour apprendre ici on a notre
expérience vieillissement donc ici c'est
des blobs qui sont qui ont différents
âges donc ici c'est notre plus vieux
blog il a deux ans et demi quand même ce
qui est assez vieux pour un blob et on
essaye de comprendre comment le blob
arrive à rajeunir parce que le blob au
bout d'un certain temps il démontre en
fait des signes de vieillesse et là où
c'est magique c'est si on endort le blob
et qu'on le ravive il est tout jeune à
nouveau donc il peut vivre finalement
presque éternellement
donc là avec quand on est on va faire
une expérience de cafétéria donc on a
plusieurs ingrédients à proposer au blob
c'est pour voir si le blob est capable
de détecter les sources de nourriture
qui sont optimales pour lui on le fait
deux fois ouais chaque globe a un petit
peu son individualité qui sont tous
différents les uns des autres et il y en
a des plus rapides il y en a qui sont
par exemple qui ont des meilleures
performances dans les prises de décision
il y en a qui arrivent à résoudre le
labyrinthe plus ou moins bien et donc on
choisit souvent le blob qui est adapté à
l'expérience donc si on a envie d'avoir
un résultat rapidement on va prendre un
bloc comme Malu qui se déplace très
rapidement et qui surtout qui est très
goulu mais lui triple de taille tous les
jours donc là on le coupe
avec un tube
on va venir le prélever
et après on va le poser au centre de la
cafétéria le blob il a pas de taille
limite il y a deux records enregistrés
le premier en 1989 c'est un blog qui
faisait 5.5 mètres carrés on a battu un
autre record avec les participants du
projet élèves ton blog le projet avec
Thomas Pesquet j'avais distribué des
blobs à 5000 établissements scolaires en
France j'avais distribué des clones du
même globe ils sont tous revenus avec
leurs clones et on les a mis les uns à
côté des autres on a formé une spirale
de 53 mètres de long donc on a battu le
record de la plus longue cellule au
monde
donc là on va mettre la cafétéria dans
une étude pour pouvoir filmer le
comportement du globe
alors la dernière expérience c'est
Antonin qui est Corse et qui a voulu
voir comment le blob arrivé à résoudre
un problème de réseau
d'autoroute en Corse et donc on peut
voir les routes qu'a choisi le bloc pour
connecter les différentes villes corses
alors cette expérience elle montre que
le blob optimisme ses réseaux et donc va
toujours faire des réseaux qui sont peu
coûteux efficaces et si on coupe une
route il pourra toujours prendre une
route alternative le blob à l'intérieur
de sa cellule il a un réseau veineux et
ce réseau veineux il est optimisé pour
transporter les nutriments les gaz dans
cette cellule géante et ce qu'on fait
les scientifiques c'est comparer ce
réseau à des réseaux ferroviaires
actuels et ils ont montré que cette
cellule était capable d'optimiser mieux
que nous parce que finalement c'est une
cellule qui depuis un milliard d'année
optimise son propre réseau de
distribution par exemple nous ici à
Toulouse on travaille avec une
entreprise qui s'appelle l'absoft qui
cherche à optimiser les réseaux de
télécommunication pour qu'il soit moins
producteur de CO2 donc on demande au
blob des solutions c'est drôle et cool
d'étudier le blog mais ça va aussi nous
permettre de faire progresser énormément
les connaissances alors
au niveau de la Croix Bleue on voit le
noyau c'est un bébé blob en réalité le
blob il est pas comme nous il y a pas de
fille de garçon
puisqu'il y a 720 type sexuels vous
savez comme nous on a X et Y comme
chromosome ben lui il a 720 possibilités
donc moi personnellement j'ai trouvé un
intérêt parce que ça fait énormément
progresser les connaissances parce que
ils nous questionne le blog il nous
questionne sur ce qu'on connaissait des
organismes vivants il nous démontre que
finalement on connaît rien qui a plein
d'organismes dans nos forêts dont on a
même pas conscience parce qu'ils sont
unicellulaires or la biomasse des
unicellulaires si on prend tous les
organismes qui sont composés d'une seule
cellule dans sur tout toute la surface
de la Terre c'est 32 fois la biomasse de
tous les animaux humains y compris et
ben ça nous donne un petit peu
d'humilité aussi ces organismes sur
lequel on marche en forêt ils ont
quelque chose à dire et ce sont des
organes qui sont fondamentaux dans les
écosystèmes puisque les mixsomi 7 donc
la grande classe des blobs ce sont des
organismes qui mangent des bactéries et
des champignons donc c'est de la matière
organique qui va être digérées et
ensuite ils vont excréter des minéraux
dans le sol
issus de la digestion de cette matière
organique et ces minéraux ils vont être
ensuite capturés par les plantes donc si
un jour vous enlevez tous les mix au
miettes d'une forêt vous aurez plus
beaucoup de plantes donc ces organismes
qui sont forts dans ma peau et pourtant
peu étudiés
[Musique]